[Applaudissements]
un vétéran de la fraternité des
grimpeurs a trouvé la mort les sponsors
lui mettez trop de pression mec il
demande toujours plus de sensations il
oblige à prendre des risques moi je veux
revenir à un alpinisme plus raisonnable
j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qui est avec toi
aujourd'hui
il y a de bonnes conditions aussi bonne
qu'on peut espérer en avoir en ce moment
Michael on aura peut-être pas d'autres
occasions mec je le ferai avec ou sans
toi
allez on va le grimper ce monstre et ben
pas trop tôt
il a été là pour moi quand j'avais
besoin de lui
m'a aidé à pas devenir cinglé et
maintenant c'est lui qui va te faire
tuer
j'appelle les secours de montagne tu
crois qu'ils vont repartir
on l'aurait fait alors on monte ou on
descend ouais
[Musique]
ils disent que l'orage a tourné
on doit dégager d'ici au plus vite
il y a rien de plus mortel que l’orgueil
quand on s'attaque à ses montagnes
la seule façon de s'en sortir c'est de
grimper tu dois me faire confiance je
vais me sortir de là